una nueva Ronda de sanciones por parte
de Estados Unidos a Rusia el
departamento del tesoro en cabeza de
Jean yelen junto a los departamentos de
estado y comercio anunciaron un largo
paquete de medidas
nuestras sanciones han tenido efecto
tanto a corto como a largo plazo que se
han hecho patentes en la lucha de Rusia
por reabastecer su armamento y en su
economía aislada nuestras acciones de
hoy con nuestros socios del g7
demuestran Que estaremos junto a Ucrania
todo el tiempo que haga falta con esta
medida pretenden castigar a 250 personas
y empresas entre ellos a una docena de
instituciones financieras 30 empresas y
personas señaladas de ayudar a Rusia
evadir las sanciones en países que van
desde emiratos árabes Unidos a Suiza y a
importadores rusos de microelectrónica y
los productores de fibra de carbono un
material clave para los sistemas de
defensa los departamentos de estado y
comercio de la oficina del representante
de comercio de Estados Unidos también
publicaron planes para aumentar la
presión estas medidas imponen
restricciones de visado a 1.219 miembros
del ejército ruso aumentan los aranceles
sobre productos rusos como el aluminio
por valor de unos 2.800 millones de
dólares y añaden cerca de 90 empresas
rusas y de países incluidas de China a
una lista de evasores de sanciones que
han sido identificados en una reunión
virtual del g7 donde asistió también el
presidente zelensky quien aprovechó Para
volver a pedir más armamento a occidente
se anunciaron sanciones en sintonía con
las de Estados Unidos como las de tomar
acciones contra terceros países que
apoyan la guerra rusa en Ucrania evitar
que Rusia importe insumos que respaldan
la industria militar y de manufactura y
por primera vez tomarán medidas contra
la comercialización de los diamantes
rusos que le dan ingresos
multimillonarios a Moscú